for over a year these young sudanese men
have been camping here near the beach in
calais
they fled conflict in their own country
now they wait to cross the channel to
the uk
pretty patel the home secretary hopes
her new immigration plan will stop them
trying
people who have come from france come
from germany come from safe countries
around the world
who then cross the channel in these
small boats in very dangerous conditions
as well
they will not be able to claim asylum in
the uk in a way in which they have been
able to
but longer prison sentences the prospect
of being sent back
or to a processing center abroad may not
prevent the most desperate like the 18
migrants found in a lorry in dover today
you are not vulnerable
because you don't you belong yeah
alfonsin cabagabo a rwandan refugee who
now runs a charity helping women seeking
asylum
says the government's plans are inhumane
oh god that makes me feel so
sad so sick because it does remind me my
own journey
when i left rwanda in 94 in the middle
of genocide and i was rescued
brought to safety in a safe country like
a bedroom and later
in the uk to rebuild my life it makes me
feel sad because
she doesn't understand that most of the
people who are coming
they are seeking safety they are feeling
wars they are feeling genocide
they have conflict they are an emergency
situation
so it's absolutely not human in my view
the home office says tougher penalties
will put people off using these
dangerous routes and promises safer
legal passage for some
it's also putting pressure on countries
who refuse to strike agreements on
immigration
agreements vital to making this plan
work now there will be repercussions for
nations who don't accept their citizens
back once the uk blocks their claims
we take back our own nationals from
around the world and every country
has that moral obligation to do so so we
will consider
penalties and it could be visas it could
be other aspects such as visa fees
or even slowing down processing we will
consider all options
however tough the government's policy is
the most desperate will keep trying to
reach the uk regardless
no matter how perilous the journey kate
mccann sky news